The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We've got three
lectures left-- today,
Thursday, and next Tuesday.
So today we're going to
talk a little bit more
about modal analysis, and we did
initial conditions last time.
This time we'll do
harmonic excitation mostly
with a little review there.
Thursday-- let me say
this slightly differently.
Modal analysis looks at
the vibration of a system
with many degrees of freedom
and looks at one mode at a time,
but you can also just solve
the whole thing at once.
You don't have to break it
down into the individual modes,
so you can come up with
a-- if you have a harmonic
excitation on a system with
many degrees of freedom,
if you put in a harmonic
force, the whole thing is going
to shake, and you can
solve it in one go,
and that's essentially using
a transfer function approach.
So this is breaking it
down one mode at a time.
Here we're going to do this
concept of transfer functions
for Hij, so response at location
i due to an excitation at j.
In a multiple degree
of freedom system,
you get many different
combinations.
So this is steady state
response, but done all at once.
And Tuesday-- and also this
has an application to something
I called dynamic absorbers.
I'll just be able to
scratch the surface of that,
but the Hancock Building across
the way-- I told you a couple
lectures back about it.
In the 1970s, it was
brand new, and the windows
were falling out.
And there was lots of
windows falling out
at the bottom and
none at the top,
and the thing was
bending back and forth
like just a cantilever,
a reed in the wind,
and one of the
fixes for it is they
put a thing called the dynamic
absorber on the 58th floor.
There are two 300 ton blocks of
lead on a pressurized oil film
so they can slide back and
forth on the 58th floor
of that building.
They're called
dynamic absorbers.
And at the expense of letting
these big blocks of lead slide
back and forth, it keeps
the building from vibrating.
It keeps the windows
from falling out.
So I hope to get to
talking a little bit
about dynamic
absorbers-- one other way
of stopping problem vibration.
And on Tuesday, we'll talk
about strings and beams.
Just a brief introduction
to continuous systems.
And that'll be our last
lecture, and probably
give you a very quick
review then of what's
going to be covered
on the final,
but mostly the final will
be covering this last third
of the course on vibration.
So let's turn to modal
analysis, and posted on Stellar
is a little too page handout
that gives you a just step
by step cookbook approach to
conducting a modal analysis.
And we're going to hit
the highlights of that
this morning as a way of
reviewing what we learned
last time and moving on to
calculating the response
to harmonic forces.
So we begin with some n degree
of freedom system linearized.
We're only dealing with
linear equations of motion.
And our first step is we
need equations of motion.
So you write them
m-- in general, you'd
write out your equations
of motion for the system,
and these x's here are just
my generalized coordinates.
They can be rotations,
deflections, whatever
makes sense in the problem.
That's the first step.
You need your
equations of motion.
Second step, find undamped
natural frequency--
is the omega i's-- I'll just
call it omega i's-- and mode
shapes.
And the mode shapes
we put into a matrix
that we call a
mode shape matrix.
I write it as u.
So that's the next
step in the problem.
The third is basically to apply
or invoke the modal expansion
theorem.
This is the key to
the whole thing,
and that is to say that you can
write the generalized motions
of the system-- the
responses of the system--
as a weighted sum of the
individual modes of the system.
So the q's are the
modal amplitudes.
The u's are the mode shape--
each mode, like the first mode,
has some amplitude
and time dependence,
and its motion is distributed
to the whole system
according to its mode shape, and
that's what that statement is.
And another way of writing
it which is more intuitive
is this is a summation
then of i equals
1 over the degrees of freedom
of the system of the mode
shapes times qi of t, the modal
amplitudes of the response
of that single degree
of freedom system
that describes
each of the modes.
Now, I should-- the
qi's are the solution
to n equations of
the form mi qi double
dot plus ci qi dot
plus ki qi equals
the excitation for that single
degree of freedom system.
So the modal
expansion theorem says
we're going to take
each mode of the system,
treat it like a single
degree of freedom problem.
And so for the first
mode, I would be 1.
You would have a modal
mass, damping, stiffness,
and a force for that mode.
And you know how to solve for
the response of a single degree
of freedom system to
initial conditions,
or the steady state response
to some harmonic input,
and you would do that
for each of the modes.
And to get back to
the final answer,
you sum them back
up again this way.
So I've put up here
on the board where
that-- the description
of that demo,
and we went through
all this information
last time so you have it in
your notes for last time.
If you missed it last
time, I put it up again.
So here's the demo on the table.
This is my diagram of it.
Mass 1, mass 2,
spring, lowercase k1,
lowercase k2-- so
the lower cases
I'm going to use to
describe system parameters.
Uppercase K's and
that sort of thing
will be my modal parameters.
So this has masses,
stiffnesses, and damping,
and this damper is connected
to the non-moving frame,
and so is this one to
model the damping sliding
up and down on that shaft.
So the equations of
motion of the system
are here in your
generalized coordinates.
And I've included
the possibility
that I could have a force
in the first mass, F1,
a force in the second mass.
So this is a completely general
set up for this problem.
Then you need to find the
natural frequencies and mode
shapes, so you assume a solution
of the form e to i omega t.
Plug in, and you get
this algebraic equation.
Minus omega squared m plus k
times some vector, which will
turn out to be the mode shapes.
And either this is
0, which is trivial,
or the determinant of this
is 0, and this gives you
the roots of this
determinant, give you
the natural frequencies
of the system.
If it's a four degree of freedom
problem, you get four roots.
So we found for this
particular problem
that the natural frequencies
are 5.65 and 17.69,
and the mass matrix, if
you weren't here last time,
in kilograms, 3.193, 0.63.
And the stiffness matrix
in newtons per meter
for that system is this.
Notice, stiffness matrices
are always symmetric,
and this one minus 36, minus 36.
And many of you have
been taking 2001.
Did anybody invoke
something called
Maxwell's reciprocal theorem?
Have you run into that?
Well, this comes from
structural analysis,
this notion of the
symmetry of the K matrix.
The mass matrix is also
going to be symmetric.
So we need to find--
to do modal analysis,
you make this calculation.
You transpose mu.
This is the transpose of
the mode shape matrix mu,
and if you do that
calculation with these numbers
and those mode shapes,
you get a new mass--
you get the modal
mass matrix, which
is guaranteed to
be diagonal, even
if it wasn't to begin with.
This is the numbers you get.
The stiffness matrix certainly
wasn't diagonal to begin with.
It looked like that.
And we multiply u
transpose times k times u,
and we get a diagonal matrix.
This element here
we'd call capital K1.
It's the modal
stiffness for mode 1.
This is the modal
mass for mode 1,
and they represent a--
they're the numbers we
need to write a single degree
of freedom equation of motion
of the kind at the bottom
of that board up there.
So we want to write
M1q1 double dot
plus some c1q1 dot plus k1q1
equals, in general, a-- this
is a 1-- some excitation, but
it's a single degree of freedom
system.
If it's a single degree
of freedom system,
what's its natural frequency
using the parameters
in this equation?
AUDIENCE: k1/m1.
PROFESSOR: Right, so
omega 1 had better
be the square root of k1/m1, and
that's the square root of-- k1
is 91-- nope.
That's the real [INAUDIBLE].
I need my u transpose k here.
113.71.
And the modal mass for
system one is 3.556.
So that's 3 or so and
100 and something.
That's neighborhood of 35, 36.
Square root of 36 is about 6.
So it needs to give
you back exactly
the correct natural
frequency, which
you found in the
beginning when you
solved for the natural
frequencies and mode
shapes of the system.
So I repeated myself here.
And if you write the
same thing-- omega 2--
it better be equal to k2/m2.
So these are just ways
of verifying that you've
done your arithmetic correctly.
And I haven't done the
damping matrix yet,
because the damping
matrices have
to be treated rather carefully.
They don't
automatically uncouple,
and so we'll address
it in just a second.
The damping matrix,
however, would
be written utcu
would give me what
I hope is a diagonalized
modal damping matrix.
I'm trying to make these
look like caps or something
to make them look a little
different from the c's
of the dashpots themselves.
We hope to find a
diagonalized damping matrix,
but we have to make some
effort to make that happen.
Finally, one thing we
haven't dealt with before.
In order to-- when we derive the
single degree of freedom modal
systems, we had to
multiply through
by this u transpose, the
original equations of motion,
and so what we haven't
worked with yet
is how do you get the
modal forces in the system?
And they come from the
calculation u transpose
times the generalized
forces in the system.
So that's a vector
times a matrix gives you
a new vector, which are
the generalized forces.
And we're going to do
that example in more
detail in a few minutes.
So last time we did the
initial conditions problem,
and we need the
results of that to do--
we need the damping that
we learned from that to do
the force vibration problem.
So let's go back and review a
little bit about what we did.
So let's let, for a moment,
the generalized forces be 0.
So no excitation.
So we're only doing an
initial conditions problem,
and let's assume that we have
some set of initial conditions
on the generalized
displacements at time 0.
So those initial conditions
on displacements--
they'll look something
like x10 down to xn0,
and we just have a two degree of
freedom system in our example.
And also you could have
an x dot at t equals 0,
and that would be some vector
of v10's down to vn0's.
And for today, we're
going to let those be 0s.
So we're just going to
have an initial deflection
in the system and
see what happens.
And we learned last time that,
since the modal expansion
theorem is what makes
this whole thing work,
the idea that x can be
written as u times q--
then we ought to be able to say
the same thing for-- if these
are initial conditions,
then we should
be able to get the initial
conditions in modal
coordinates.
So x at 0 here is also
u at the q's at 0,
but we normally
would specify these.
We need to know those.
Well, to get these I just
multiply through by u inverse
so that the q, the vector of the
initial displacements in modal
coordinates, is just
equal to u inverse times
the initial conditions--
the initial deflections
in the generalized coordinates.
And q dot at 0, if you had
non-zero initial velocities,
would be u inverse
times x dot at time 0.
So let me tell you
where we're going.
I'm not going to
go back all the way
through the initial
conditions problem.
That was last lecture.
I'm going to review
the results of it,
because what I want to
get to is, how do you
compute the response by
modal analysis-- the response
to a harmonic force?
For example, if you
get close to resonance
for a single degree
of freedom system,
what controls the
height of that peak?
If you drive a single degree
of freedom system at resonance,
what's the most
important parameter?
AUDIENCE: Damping [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Damping.
So we really need
to know damping.
And the way we get damping is--
one of the ways is measure it.
So I want to measure
the right damping
so that I can do--
what I'm trying
to get to is to do the
force vibration problem,
but I need to get some
estimates of damping to do it.
Now, I said damping
can sometimes
be a problem, so I'm
going to show you--
I alluded to this
damp last time,
but I wasn't able to kind of
really clearly go through it.
So I'm going to make a damping
model, my damping matrix
for my system such
that it is proportional
to the original mass and
stiffness matrix of the system.
So alpha is just a parameter
that I get to choose.
Beta is another one
that I get to choose,
and this is m and
k, the original mass
and stiffness matrices
of this problem
or any n degree of
freedom problem.
We're doing these two
degree of freedom examples
because they're
tractable on the board.
So if I make my damping
matrix look like that,
it is guaranteed to work when I
do u transpose times that times
u, because we know the mass
and stiffness matrices give me
diagonals, so I'm just
essentially doing that again.
So this is guaranteed to
give me a diagonal matrix.
It's what I want.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So are those
the original mass?
PROFESSOR: Yes, these
are the original ones.
Usually, if I'm really trying
to write the modal ones,
I'll draw them with a diagonal
through them or something just
to-- so these are m and
k, just like up here.
Right there.
They're right from
the original system.
They're the ones on
the top of this board.
There's the mass matrix,
damping matrix, stiffness matrix
for the original
equations of motion.
So I am saying that my
unspecified damping matrix,
which is written
as c1, c2 there--
I'm going to
represent it this way,
so that u transpose cu, which
is the calculation I need
to be able to do-- what
that gives me is an alpha,
and here's my modal
mass, diagonalized
modal mass matrix that
results, plus a beta
times my diagonalized
stiffness matrices.
So Christina, these guys are
the modal ones after doing
u transpose mu, u transpose ku.
So we have a two degree
of freedom system,
and when I do this
calculation, I'll
get modal mass m1, m2, k1, k2.
So the final diagonalized
stiffness matrix
will end up looking like some
capital C10, capital C2 here.
That's my diagonalized
damping matrix.
It'll come from these, and
I'll just write them out.
So the C1 will be an
alpha m1 plus beta k1,
and C2 will be alpha
m2 plus beta k2.
So I have two free
parameters with which
I can fit-- I can fit
those parameters to give me
the damping that I want,
and I'm going to measure
the damping in the system.
And then I'm going
to find the two
parameters that make that work.
That's why I'm
going through this.
All right, running out of room.
So zeta 1, the damping
ratio for mode 1--
if it's a single degree
of freedom system,
you say, oh, well that's
the damping constant over 2
omega 1 m1.
That's how we
define damping ratio
for a single degree
of freedom system,
but we know what
these quantities are.
This then is an alpha
m1 over 2 omega 1 m1
plus a beta k1
over 2 omega 1 m1.
k1/m1 is omega 1 squared.
So put omega 1 squared up here.
Cancel with that.
These two gives you-- this
gives you alpha over 2
omega 1 plus beta
omega 1 over 2,
and I can do the same
thing for zeta 2.
Be my c2 over 2 omega 2 m2, and
that'll give me an alpha over 2
omega 2 plus beta
omega 2 over 2.
So if I can measure a value
for this damping and a value
for that damping, I have.
These are known then.
I have two equations
and two unknowns, alpha
and beta-- just algebraic
equations that I can solve.
So now I need to
conduct my experiment.
I have this system.
Without external
excitation, it's
just a free vibration system--
typical equations of motion.
The first mode would
look like m1q1 double dot
plus c1q1 dot plus
k1q1 equals 0.
I'm looking for
solutions to that,
and there's a similar
one for the second mode.
And what I want to
do is excite only one
of these modes at a time.
Now, you've seen this
demo done before,
but at a certain
combination of deflections,
it'll respond only in mode
1, and a different one
will respond only in mode 2.
And it's guaranteed
that, if you deflect
a system in the shape of one
of its modes and let it go,
it will only vibrate
in that mode,
but let's prove to
ourselves that that actually
is going to work.
So I'm going to let, for
example, initial conditions--
x10, x20-- be in
the shape of mode 1.
Well mode 1 is 1, 2.2667--
is the mode shape of mode 1.
I'm just going to let that be.
I'm going to deflect it
in the shape of mode one,
and I'm going to let x10 dot
and x20 dot-- those are 0.
And I need to
know, if I do that,
what are the resulting
initial conditions
in modal coordinates?
Well, we know q10 and
q20-- I can obtain them
by doing u inverse times this.
So this will be u inverse-- last
time-- I'm going to write this.
Last time I made a mistake.
So u inverse-- I left out a 0.
So 0.0898, 0.9102,
0.4016, minus 0.4016.
So that's u inverse, and
I'm going to multiply it
by one of the mode shapes.
1 and 2.2667.
So I'm saying that
my initial conditions
are going to look exactly
like one mode shape.
To compute the equivalent
modal initial conditions,
I multiply the generalized the
coordinate initial conditions
by u inverse.
Here's u inverse times that,
and if I do that calculation,
I get exactly 1, 0.
And if instead of
the first mode shape
I put in the second mode
shape, the 1 minus 0.2236--
if I did that, I would
get exactly 0, 1.
So I just wanted to go through
that just so you'd see it--
that the math bears it out.
If you put in a
deflection that's exactly
the shape of a mode,
then you will get back
an equivalent initial condition
in the modal coordinates
for only that mode and
everything else will be 0.
So that's q.
This is q10-- is that guy.
And this q20 in this case is 0.
OK?
So now we're ready
to do the experiment.
So if I deflected in the shape
of mode 1-- come back here.
And now would be a good time to
lower the lights a little bit.
And unfortunately we have that
white chalk in the background
to distract us, but
it's now deflected only
in the shape of
mode 1, and now it's
going to behave like a single
degree of freedom system,
right?
So how would you estimate--
do a quick estimate
of the damping of mode 1.
I gave you a little
quick, easy rule
you could use a few times back.
What was it?
AUDIENCE: Do the 50% thing?
PROFESSOR: Do the 50%
thing she suggests.
Now, can you be a
little more specific.
Pardon?
AUDIENCE: The half life.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, how many--
what am I looking for?
How many--
AUDIENCE: Cycles.
PROFESSOR: Cycles it takes
for the thing to decay 50%.
So the reference line is here.
I've deflected it that far,
and it'll start vibrating,
and when the top of
this on a vibration
gets to the halfway
point between here
and the reference--
reference is where
it starts-- that'll be my 50%.
So one, two, three, four.
Got about four cycles when
it only went down halfway.
Now, when I did it in
my office the other day,
I only got 2 and 1/2 cycles.
So we're going to use 2
and 1/2 cycles because I
ran the numbers for that.
This thing is very
sensitive if it's
inclined a little bit,
because that changes
the friction on the shaft.
So in my office the other day,
there was a lot more damping.
So anyway, pretend
it's 2 and 1/2.
Now, while we're at it,
let's do the other case.
So the other case we
want to deflect it
in the shape of mode 2.
So I go down, say,
a unit amount.
It's now deflected downward
some amount and upwards such
that the ratio is in the
mode shape of mode 2.
So every unit I went down,
I go up minus 22% of that.
So that's what's been done here.
So when I release this
one, now the reference line
for the second one is
up here down to here.
So when this upper one decays
to halfway-- about here--
that'll be the number of cycles.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
Anyway, in my office
I got about 10.
We're going to use my numbers,
but that one is clearly
a lot less damped.
That thing just went on, an
on, and on, and on, and on.
So in our experiment then-- so
we conducted our experiment.
Zeta 1 is approximately
equal to point 1.1
over the number of
cycles to decay 50%,
and when I did the
experiment in my office,
that was 0.11 over 2.5.
So it was really decaying
fast, and so when you only
have two or three
cycles, it helps
to use even fractional cycles.
And it's OK to use
fractional cycles.
This is just an estimate.
That's going to
give us a number.
Zeta 2 is approximately
0.11 over the number
of cycles to decay 50%,
and in this case, that's
going to be 10.
And so that gives me 0.011, or
what's known as 1.1% damping.
And the other one,
0.11/2.5, gives me 0.044,
or 4.4% damping.
Percent of what?
Anybody remember what
happens when you're at 1?
Have a damping ratio of 1.0?
AUDIENCE: Critical damping.
PROFESSOR: That's
critical damping.
That's that crossover point.
If you have 1 or greater,
you get no oscillation.
It just goes and stops.
Less than 1, it will
actually across 0
and oscillate a little bit.
Well, now I have
values for 0.044 0.011
that I can plug in to
these two equations,
and I now have two equations and
two unknowns, alpha and beta,
because I know
omega 1 and omega 2.
So solve for alpha,
and for alpha I'm not
going to do that on the board.
It's kind of a waste
of good lecture time.
10.71.
And beta, minus 0.033.
So they can be positive or
negative to make these work
out, but those are the
two values you need,
and that says that we're going
to model the damping matrix
of the system as 10.71m
plus minus 0.033k.
And we'll compute the
diagonalized damping matrix,
which comes from utcu,
and did I write that down?
I didn't, but I don't need
it, because I know the damping
that I'm after 0.044 and
0.011, because in order
to complete this problem, if
I wanted to go to completion
and have the transient
decay of the system,
I would have it in for each
of the two modal systems.
q of t for the first mode would
be some e to the minus zeta
1 omega 1t cosine omega
1-- I left out my q10.
q10 cosine omega 1d
times t-- that's the most
of the initial displacement
part-- plus q10 dot plus zeta
1 omega 1 q10.
All of that over omega 1d.
All of this times sine
omega 1d times time.
So this is just the response to
initial conditions for a single
degree of freedom system, and
you'd have a similar one for q2
of t, except now all the ones
would be replaced by 2's.
So you have an e to the
minus zeta 2 omega 2t times--
and those are your
two-- that would
be in general the response
to initial conditions
in modal terms.
And if you want to get
back to the final response
in your generalized coordinates,
then it's just summation
i equals 1 to 2, in this
case, of u mode shape,
or mode 1, q1 plus mode
shape for mode 2 q2 of t.
So these two added together
would give you total response.
So that's the response.
Kind of a quick review of
what we learned before.
Response to initial
conditions, but now
along the way we've learned
how to experimentally fix
the damping matrix,
so it'll work,
and actually get it to give us
exact accurate results if we
want to do a response to any
initial conditions problem.
But now we also have damping
ratios for this system,
and we can now go on to do
the force vibration problem.
And the force
vibration problem will
be pretty easy at this point.
So that was a quick review of
response to initial conditions
by modal analysis-- how to find
a damping matrix that works.
We've also proven
that, if you deflect
a system in the shape of a mode,
it responds only in that mode.
That's all pretty
use-- and that's
generally true of
vibration systems.
So we know-- I banged
on this before.
We know these things
like to shake a little.
They're flexible, and
this one has a mode shape.
It's kind of a cantilever.
It's first mode.
It bends like that a
little bit, and this thing
has to bend with it.
But if I were able to
just give this thing
an initial deflection just
in the shape of that mode
and let it go, it will
vibrate in just that mode.
And if I do it in some
other contorted way
that its initial shape isn't
just one mode and let it go,
it'll vibrate in a
couple different modes.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a way to visualize
the modal coordinates?
Would they be the center of
a mass of certain things,
or would they would
be the center masses
of the springs or something?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I
taught a vibration course
for many, many years, and I
scratched my head long and hard
to try to come up
with an example
where you could do
exactly what you asked.
I know of one
example that works.
In general, the
modal coordinates--
it's a coordinate
transformation into some system
that it's very hard to place
yourself physically so you can
see what's going on, but
to answer your question
I'll show you one and you
still have enough time
to get through the other part.
Imagine this eraser.
It's a car, a car automobile
suspension system.
So here's the car.
Sits on springs, the tires
and its suspension system.
Got a center of mass
that's here somewhere.
And I'm only going to consider
vertical motion of this thing.
Now, you can imagine that
it could go up and down,
but you can imagine it can
also pitch back and forth.
So I'm going to have two
generalized coordinates.
One is the vertical deflection
of its center of mass,
and the other is
the angular rotation
of the center of
mass with respect
to my initial horizontal.
Now, you get equations
of motion of this.
One, you'll get an mx
double dot kind of equation
by summing the forces
on this and the forces
from the springs.
And of course
you'll have dampers
and those kinds of things.
So you'll have
one force equation
by summing the forces on it.
You'll have another equation
that's sum of torques,
and it's an i theta double
dot kind of equation.
So it'll be a two degree
of freedom system.
You'll get two
natural frequencies,
and two mode shapes.
And the two natural
frequencies look
approximate-- the two
mode shapes look-- here
is the original
undeflected system.
One mode shape the system
moves up and rotates up.
It has both positive rotation
and some positive deflection.
And I need to draw this
over here a little further.
So here's the original system.
It moves up in its
mode shape like that,
and when it goes down to its
max negative, it's like that.
So it goes through a motion.
And if you think about it,
if you extend these lines out
here, you come to a point
that this intersects.
And so in fact,
in the first mode
of vibration of this thing, if
you went and sat right here,
you would just see this
thing go through an angle.
And that, in fact, is the
modal coordinate for mode 1.
And the second mode
I've kind of forgotten.
It goes has a sign
change, and so when
you're going--
deflecting upwards,
it goes-- positive flexion
upwards-- it tips downwards.
And when it goes the other
way, it goes like that.
So this one, it goes
up and rotates up.
And the second mode, when
it goes up, it rotates down.
And out here is the point at
which you could go sit there,
and you would just see this
thing rotate up, rotate down
if you went and sat there.
So you move yourself
to a place where
you can see with a
single coordinate--
with only the angle
measured by this point,
you can completely
describe that modal motion.
And with only the angle
measured around this point,
you can describe
the modal motion.
But in general, you can't do it.
So if I'm out here-- if
my eye is at this point,
I'll see this
thing go like that.
That help?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, a lot.
PROFESSOR: So one of the
hardest things for me
as a lecturer is, since
I really like vibration
and I've taught it
for 35 years or so,
to try to cram everything I know
about vibration into the one
third of this course.
So I obviously don't do that.
So I'm trying to give you--
my goal then becomes give you
some basic insight
about vibration
so that, when you do get
out there in the real world
and you need to know something,
need to solve a vibration
problem, you'll know
the fundamentals,
and you'll know where
to go look it up.
And if you want to take
another course or something
in vibration, you can do that.
All right, now we've got to
do, in relatively short order,
response of our initial
system over here
to some harmonic excitation.
And the one I've
chosen to do-- let's
imagine that I
just-- I'm just going
to put a force, a harmonic
force, on this mass,
and I want the steady
state response.
And you can imagine, if I do it
close to the natural frequency
of one of the modes, you're
going to get a lot of that,
but if I do it close to
the natural frequency
of the other mode,
I can do it too.
So let's do the steady state
harmonic excitation problem.
So we're going to
do this problem.
F2 of t-- so my generalized
forces are 0 some magnitude
Ft e to the i omega t.
And the modal forces
are u transpose F,
and that would be
the calculation
one and 2.2667, and 1, and minus
0.2236-- my two mode shapes
transposed multiplied
by 0 and F2.
So that says that q1 is
F2.2667 F2e to the i omega t.
And q2, the modal
force for mode 2,
is this times that-- is minus
0.2236 F2 e to the i omega t.
So I've put on just
a force on one mass,
but it gets distributed in a way
that it'll excite both modes,
and it'll excite mode one
in an amount 2.2 times F2.
And it'll excite mode 2
in an amount minus 0.22.
So mode 1 is going to
get more excitation
in this particular case because
of the shape of the modes.
The bigger the
modal deflection is
at the point of
application of the force,
the more that mode
is going to get.
Well, now these gave you
two equations of motion.
m1q1 double dot
plus c1q1 dot k1q1
equals, in the case of mode 1,
2.2667 F2 e to the i omega t.
And that's a single
degree of freedom system
excited by a harmonic force.
We worked that problem.
We know what the
answer looks like.
So for example, the
magnitude of the response q1
is given by the magnitude
of the force q2 times
the magnitude of a transfer
function, which is the response
q1 per unit input force
q1 evaluated at whatever
frequency I evaluate it at.
So the magnitude of
the response magnitude
of the modal force
times the transfer
function, and this
transfer function
is this exactly the
same form as when
we did just the single degree
of freedom system as x/F.
That's what I called the
response x over input force F.
Same thing, where just
now the response is q,
and the input
force is capital Q.
Therefore, that looks
like magnitude of Q--
and I made a mistake here.
Q1.
The magnitude of force Q1,
which is this, times 1/k1--
this should look familiar--
1 minus omega squared
over omega 1 squared
squared plus 2 zeta
1 omega over omega 1
quantity squared square root.
So there's that transfer
function expression.
At resonance, for example,
all this goes to 0.
Omega over omega 1 goes to 1.
This whole denominator
turns into 1/2 times
the damping ratio, for example.
And Q1 over k1 is
the static deflection
of the system under the
load-- under a static load
of that large.
So I'll do the problem.
If the excitation
frequency happens
to be right on the natural
frequency for mode one,
then I can evaluate this at
1 omega over omega 1 is 1,
and I've worked that out.
That says that
magnitude of q1 here--
2.2667F2/k1 times
1 over 2 zeta one.
That's what all
this condenses to.
We know what k1 is.
We know what zeta 1 is.
F2 is the thing
we're specifying.
And so zeta 1 for example
is what-- it was 0.044.
So you plug in your 0.044 here,
and this whole thing works out
to be-- actually I'll write
down the numbers here--
2.2667F2/k1 is
10984, and not 109.
That's k2.
113.71 times 11.36,
which is 1/2 times zeta.
1/0.088 is 11.36.
The final analysis--
q1 is 0.227F2.
So it's just a single degree
of freedom system excited
by harmonic force,
and you can figure out
how big its response is.
I could do the same
thing for mode 2.
Is mode 2 resonant?
No.
So this is instructive.
The magnitude of
the responsive q2
is the magnitude of the
force times the magnitude
of the Hq2 per unit input 2q.
It looks like that, but
this time this is minus
0.2236F2/109.84, which is k2.
And then all of the denominator
involving one minus-- and this
will now be omega--
over omega 2 squared
squared plus 2 zeta 2 omega over
omega 2 squared square root.
This number here is k2.
The reason I'm going
to this is this one
is not resonant, and
in fact, what's omega?
Well, in fact, what
is the excite--
I started this problem.
I said let the excitation
frequency be what?
Natural frequency of mode 1.
So omega in this
case equals omega 1.
Therefore, for this
problem, omega over omega 2
is omega 1 over omega 2,
and that's 5.65 something
over 17 point something.
It's about 1/3.
So we are exciting
the second mode
at about 1/3 its
natural frequency.
And so this is 1 minus 1/3
quantity squared and so forth.
And if I run the
numbers, I just want
you to see what happens
with the numbers.
This turns out to be
0.806, and this turns out
to be-- remember this
is 0.01 something here.
This number turns out to be 5
times 10 to the minus fifth.
That's a really small number.
And this whole square
root of this stuff
turns out to be 0.898.
And in the end, q2 works out-
the magnitude of q2 works out
to be 0.0023F2.
I did this on purpose.
If, when you're at resonance,
meaning the excitation
frequency is close to
the natural frequency
for any linear vibration system,
then this term is important,
and it'll be the most important
term in the denominator,
because this term goes to 0.
It's the only term
in the denominator,
and it's likely be quite small.
That's why it gives you
one over that big response,
but when you're not-- when this
denominator-- if you're not
at resonance, this term
almost always is negligible,
and it's this term
that governs it.
So here you are at 0.8
versus 10 to the minus fifth.
So away from resonance,
this term is important,
and on resonance,
that one is important.
And now, how would you
get back to-- we've now
got the two responses.
How do we compute the
total system response?
How would you do it?
The modal expansion theorem.
AUDIENCE: Put it back
into x [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
x equals u cubed.
That's where we started.
And q1, since this is a
harmonic excitation problem,
if the input had been
e to the i omega t,
then the output is some e to the
i omega t minus a phase angle.
So this is going to look
like some q1 amplitude.
Say, cosine omega 1t minus
phi 1 but at resonance,
we know the phase
angle is pi over 2.
And q2 of t is going
to be the amplitude q2
times some cosine omega 1t--
because that's the excitation
frequency-- minus phi 2.
And remember, each
of these systems--
these transfer functions,
Hq/Q for whichever one
it happens to be
looks like this.
Different amounts of damping
give you different heights
of the peak at resonance.
And this is omega over omega i.
So when you're at
resonance, you're at 1.
So what we've done is we have
a two degree of freedom system.
We're exciting it at the
natural frequency of mode 1.
So it means for mode
1, we're right here.
Let's say that's
where our damping is,
so that's going
to be our transfer
function for that mode, but
drawn on the same figure,
where are we for mode 2?
We're at omega 1 over
omega 2, which is somewhere
in the neighborhood of 0.3.
So we are in here.
So this is omega over omega 2.
This is omega over omega 1.
So down here,
we're at about 0.3.
Here we're at 1.0, so we're at
resonance for one of the modes,
and we're here in what's called
the stiffness controlled region
for the other mode.
This mode-- mode 2 basically
acts like a spring.
The dynamic
amplification is about 1.
It just gives you the
static response for mode 2
and the resonant
response for mode 1.
I know what I was going
to draw to remind you.
This figure has a phase
diagram that goes with it,
and for lightly damped
systems, it goes from 0 to pi.
And at resonance, all
of them cross pi over 2.
When it's a response to a force,
a simple force, at resonance,
the phase angle is pi
over 2, so the response
lags the input by 90 degrees.
When you're down
here in this region,
the response moves
with the input.
The phase angle is
basically 0, and up in here
the phase angle is 180 degrees.
It acts like a driving mass.
So our two responses
look like that,
and to get back into
modal coordinates, x1,
x2 is going to look like
u1 q1 of t plus u2 q2 of t.
It's harmonic.
Steady state response.
You know the
amplitudes, q1 and q2.
We figured them out.
One of them is 2-- q1
turned out to be 0.227F2,
and q2 is 0.0023F2.
And this one, point
cosine cosine.
So if we do that, if you put
your excitation only on here,
it's trying to tell
you that mostly you'll
get mode 1, and not much
mode 2, but that's primarily
caused because you chose
to put the excitation
frequency at where?
The natural frequency
of mode one.
So if I had made my excitation
here the same place,
but made the frequency close to
the natural frequency of mode
2, which of the two modes
would have dominated?
Mode 2.
So I've got another little demo.
We're doing well.
Out of necessity, to
do it on the blackboard
and in relatively
short time, we've
only talked about a two degree
of freedom two rigid body
system.
This is a continuous system.
It's a taut string.
It's your violin string, and
I've put some white tags on it
so that you could see it
against black backgrounds.
Everything that we've learned
about the behavior of this two
degree of freedom system
will apply to a three,
or four, or five degree
of freedom system,
but actually the
basic lessons apply
to continuous systems, too.
So the lesson we just learned
is, if you excite a system,
this has many
natural frequencies.
And in fact, if the
first one is at 1 Hertz,
which this just about is--
maybe a little more than that.
First mode is like that.
Maybe 2 Hertz.
The second mode is twice that.
Third mode is three times that.
It happens to be really simple.
So if I put a force-- the
only force in this problem--
I'm going to do the
analogous problem here.
Harmonic excitation-- I'm going
to do it in one little place
right here, and if I drive this
system at the natural frequency
of mode 1, what do you see?
What mode is
dominating response?
Mode 1.
Very, very small
responses of other modes.
So now if I can get the system
to stop shaking, if I drive it
at exactly the same place at
a different natural frequency,
I see 3/2 sine waves there.
So I was driving it at
the natural frequency of?
AUDIENCE: Mode 3.
PROFESSOR: Mode 3.
And there's no mode 1.
No mode 2.
Now I need a helper.
Can somebody come
hang onto this for me?
You've got to keep
the tension on it.
So now I'm going to teach
you a really important lesson
about systems exciting systems.
The second mode-- I might have
a hard time driving it here.
Let me see if I can get
the second mode going.
There's second mode.
I has a node right here.
There's a point right
here with no motion.
If I sit here, and I'm going
to let the system stop--
if I drive this system at the
second mode natural frequency
right here, what will happen?
Pardon?
AUDIENCE: It would be mode 1.
PROFESSOR: Maybe [INAUDIBLE] 1.
But how much mode 2 will I get?
So another lesson here is that
continuous systems have nodes,
points of no motion,
and the second mode
happens to have a
node right here.
This point doesn't
move one when it's
vibrating in the second mode.
And the modal force
looks something
like the generalized
force times a mode shape,
u transpose F. That's
how we got the-- you have
to multiply the generalized
external force times the mode
shape to get the modal force.
Well, here's my
generalized force.
What's the amplitude
of the mode shape here?
0.
F times 0 is 0.
There is just no way
I can get this thing
to vibrate in the second
mode by driving it at a node,
and that's just generally true.
Take it to the bank
and remember that.
Thank you.
All right.
Something else I wanted to do.
I need you back.
So when you give a system
an initial deflection,
because when we want to
get initial conditions,
we said that the equivalent
modal initial conditions were
u inverse times the u inverse
times to the initial conditions
in generalized coordinates.
So for a continuous
system, this thing
has mode shapes that look
like sine and pi x over l.
Those are the mode shapes.
And if I take this
thing and grab it
about in the middle,
wherever that node was,
and give it an
initial deflection,
the shape that
initial deflection
is kind of a triangle.
You've all had Fourier series.
This a triangular shape.
Could you express this shape
as a Fourier sine series?
Sure.
And it just happens that sine
waves are the mode shapes.
So you would be coming
up-- the Fourier
coefficients are
the modal amplitudes
of n initial conditions.
And so whatever the Fourier
coefficients for this are
are the modal amplitudes
for each of the modes.
So which mode do
you think is going
to-- which Fourier
sign component is going
to be largest in this one?
AUDIENCE: Mode 1?
PROFESSOR: Mode 1.
By the way, all even
numbered modes would be 0
because they're asymmetric.
This is a symmetrically
shaped pulse.
The modal initial conditions
for 2, 4, 6, 8, 10 are 0.
You will get non-zero Fourier
coefficients for 1, 3, 5, 7.
The biggest one is mode 1.
So what do you expect to
see if I let go of this?
Vibration primarily at?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: And a little
bit of some others.
Now, let's say they all
had about the same damping.
Let's say they all
had 10% damping.
No, excuse me.
All had 1% damping.
That means they'll go
through about 10 cycles
to decay to halfway.
So if they all have
the same damping,
even if there are several
other modes present,
which ones are going
to last longer in time?
Mode 1, because it takes
just longer in time
to get to 10 cycles.
The other modes
get there quicker.
If you take a guitar string
and plunk it, or a violin,
or a piano, you'll
hear the basic tone.
And what makes it sound nice,
you have those nice overtones,
but if you listen carefully,
the overtones die out usually,
and you're left with the
fundamental at the end.
If you smack a piano
key hard, you'll
get an interesting
sound at the beginning,
and then it'll mellow out.
And you'll hear just a
pure tone at the end,
and that's because the higher
frequencies damp out quicker
because they get in more
cycles per unit of time.
That's the other quick lesson.
I have one thing I
want to explain to you
which will help maybe a little
conceptual understanding
about-- this came up in
a homework discussion--
and that is just a note
about stiffness matrices.
There's a really fast easy way
to assemble stiffness matrices.
So here's a three mass system
and a spring, spring, spring.
And I'm going to put a
spring here and one here.
k1, k2, k3, k4,
k5, and k6-- and I
want to get my stiffness matrix.
The stiffness matrix-- this is a
three degree of freedom system.
It'll be a 3 by 3, and
it'll have elements up here,
which I'll call k11, k12,
k13, k21, k23, k31, k22,
and so forth.
So what's the new
meaning of kij?
So ki11-- i as 1.
J is 1.
If you can understand the
interpretation of what
a stiffness matrix
is, it'll help
you make it much easier
for you to find them.
So kij is the
force required at i
due to a unit deflection
at j due to sounds
kind of like a causal thing.
I don't quite mean that, but
so let's think about this.
What's k11?
So k11 is the force required
at 1 per unit deflection at 1.
So if I take this system and
I make it move over one unit,
and the other-- this is now
x1 here, by the way. x1,
x2, x300 so x2 and x3 are 0.
I do this one a time.
I move this over one unit.
How much force does it
take to make that happen?
A real system.
You're grabbing it.
You're pulling it over one unit.
You're making some springs move.
How much force does it
take to move that one one
unit holding these still?
Well, you're going to-- one,
force on a spring is kx.
If x is one, the force for
trying to stretch this spring
is k1 times 1.
The force required to push
on that spring as k5 times
5-- k5 times 1. k2 times one.
The k11, this first
element, is the sum
of all of the springs
connected to it.
k1 plus k2 plus k5.
So how about k12?
k12 is the force required at
1-- actually, let me do k21.
Make a little more
sense-- is the force
required at 2, because I've
moved the system one unit at 1.
That's what the problem--
that's this thing I've done.
I've moved this one unit.
In order to keep
this one from moving,
do I have to apply force to it?
How big?
AUDIENCE: k2.
PROFESSOR: k2 or minus k2?
This thing is pushing,
going over one unit.
It compresses that spring.
It's pushing on this thing.
I say it cannot move.
What do I have to do?
Push back minus k2, and you
can go through-- and then how
about number 3?
What's the force required at 3
because I've moved the one at 1
by 1 unit?
Move this over.
Are there any springs
connected to mass 3 that
are affected by that motion?
AUDIENCE: k5.
PROFESSOR: k5, and it pushes
on it through that spring,
so I have to resist by--
so k31 equals minus k5.
So now then you go on.
If you want to
get the next ones,
OK, you go to the next system.
This is now can't move.
This can't move.
We're going to let this
be unit deflection.
So unit deflection at
two, add up the springs.
k2 plus k3 plus k6--
and that's all there is.
So k22, k2 plus k3
plus k6, and then you
go through all the
ones that it affects,
and you'll get
minus this and that.
So that's the meaning.
Each of the elements of
that stiffness matrix
have that meaning to it.
And to give this closure,
we have equation of motion,
but the stiffness matrices also
applies to the statics problem.
So you have mx double dot
plus cx dot plus kx equals
F. What if I only want
to do a statics problem?
I'm going to put a
static force on here,
and I want to know
the deflections,
or I'm going to
cause deflections,
and I want to know what
force it takes to do it.
Well, the static problems--
let this be 0, this be 0.
And it says kx equals F.
So in this three degree
of freedom system, what
forces are required to cause
the deflection 0, 0, 1.
I want to deflect it one
unit on the third mass only.
What forces do I apply it to
the system to make it happen?
Well, you just multiply it out.
This is F1, F2, F3.
So it'll only be this one.
This times this, this, and this.
The only ones that matter
are these three here,
and this will end up
being k31 times 1.
This will be k-- I guess
I've got to round-- 13.
And we get 21, 22, 23, k33.
Those are the three
forces required.
You put on those forces.
Force is equal to these amounts.
You will get that deflection.
So that's just a little help.
That gives you a little
insight as to what
stiffness matrices mean.
So you can do them
by inspection.
Once you understand that, you
can actually just fill them
in by inspection, just by
doing unit displacements
at each place and
adding up the forces.
See you on Thursday.